Can Bitcoin really become the
world's reserve currency if it
doesn't displace the dollar, the
euro or the yuan as an everyday
medium of exchange?
Why isn't its price increasing
as inflation rises to levels
not seen in 40 years?
What sorts of regulations, if
any, would best facilitate
the wide scale adoption of Bitcoin,
not just among the wealthy but the
unbanked of the world?
Avik Roy is the president of the
Foundation for Research on Equal
Opportunity an Austin, Texas,
based think tank that focuses
on economic growth and mobility.
He says that Bitcoin improves on the
ability of gold as a non-state
backed store of value and has
shown itself to be effectively
uncensored revolt qualities that
will allow it to act as a game
changing restraint on
the worst actions of governments
and central banks.
Reason spoke with him at the Bitcoin
conference in Miami in April.
Avik Roy, thanks for talking to
Reason.
Nick,it's always an honor.
So can
Bitcoin become the standard
of reserve currency, the standard
payment system?
Well, I would say there's there's
there's a couple of ways to answer
that question.
And the short answer is yes.
But it's important, I think, to
understand that the traditional
conception of money is wrong.
So most people, if they've heard
a definition of money from an
economist, an academic economist,
they'll hear this definition which
goes something like this.
There's three attributes to money.
The first is that it has to be a
medium of exchange.
The second is that it's a unit of
account, meaning like you balance
your books on that on the
denomination of that currency.
And the third is that it's a store
of value, meaning you can put it in
the bank and know it's not going to
collapse in value.
Right.
And the the argument that you
hear a lot of academics make against
Bitcoin is that, well, it's not a
me, it's not a unit of account.
It's not really a medium of exchange
today.
It may be it's a store of value.
So it's one out of three.
Well, I would argue the US dollar
is only two out of three.
It's not really a good store of
value today.
Leave aside the most recent
spurt of inflation.
If you just think about the 2%
paradigm that the Fed has been on
for the last 40 years.
If you put your money in a bank at
0% interest rates
and it depreciated by 2% every
year in roughly
25 years, it would lose half of its
value.
That's not good.
Right. That's that is a punishment
to saving.
In fact, that's the whole point.
The whole Keynesian argument
as to why we have to have inflation
is because if we don't, people won't
be incentivized to spend their money
now instead of saving it.
So the whole idea is for the
government to steer you into
spending your money. So all that to
say that if
the argument is that the US dollar
is money and Bitcoin
is not because the US
dollar meets these three tests and
Bitcoin does not, that's not
actually true because the US dollar
only meets two of the three.
It's not a good store of value.
Now
taking it to the next level.
So Friedrich Hayek, among others,
makes the argument that the
way to think about money is not in
that sort of binary way of yes or
no. Does it meet these?
Can you check these three boxes?
It's that all
forms of money exist
on a spectrum of moneyness in
each of these dimensions.
And different types of money can be
more useful in some dimensions
versus others. So, for example, some
forms of money may be more useful
as mediums of exchange because
they're, say, more widely accepted
by merchants.
So there's a network effect there.
Some units of money may be more
useful as stores of value because
they don't get inflated away like
Bitcoin. Right.
So if you think about money in
those dimensions, meaning like
different types of clothes that you
would wear some to a dinner party,
some to a bitcoin conference,
some to a Reason dinner,
different kinds of money can have
different purposes.
And I would say that where
Bitcoin is most dominant
is as a store of value.
It seems pretty clear today.
The writing is on the wall that
and I argued this in a piece I wrote
for National Affairs last year
that Bitcoin is destined
to transcend the US Treasury
bond as a store
of value, which is very important.
It's not as important whether
or not the US dollar or Bitcoin
is the dominant medium of exchange.
I'll give you an example. I was in
Portugal for a conference a couple
of weeks ago. I never drew
a single euro out of an ATM.
I never paid with paper, currency or
coins in euros for anything.
I used my American issued credit
cards for every single transaction I
made and the exchange between
the US dollar in a year all happened
on the back end, right?
That can happen with bitcoin too.
If you have a bank account,
quote unquote, whether it's a wallet
or something that's custody, that's
based denominated in Bitcoin and
you're spending money off of that
with a USD accepting
merchant that can do all that.
All of that conversion can happen on
the back end. You don't have to
really care. So this whole idea
of a medium of exchange being
important, I actually don't think
it's that important.
I think it's overstated both by
bitcoiners and non bitcoiners,
what really matters and
what's really going to create the
social transformation of this
century for both good and for ill in
terms of the disruption will cause?
Is Bitcoin being a better store of
value than the US dollar?